there you get a look at right-hander
jimmy lambert that's what he did this
year at charlotte with 13 starts era
respectable you see a lot of strikeouts
for innings pitch this is what he's
going to feature the four-seam fastball
close to half the time
so lambert
gets zimmer looking to start it two and
two count on framil reyes here comes
lambert
a grounder to short anderson over to
hernandez six four three double play at
a one hopper cal quanto making his 12th
start two and two record and we told you
he's been pitching very well in in the
month of july should have won his last
uh you know two starts the bullpen has
given up seven runs in those uh outings
that he has had
the next pitch swung down a little
floater foul down the third base side
near the tarp and a great backhanded
running catch by jose ramirez sure did
on a play by jose ramirez
hey got him looking at a fastball
it may have tickled the outside corner
oscar mercado
will lead off
the top of the second for
cleveland mercado on the ground
and moncada gets him as sheets stayed on
the bag roberto perez
got him
perfectly placed fastball sebby sets up
the ball is right there i mean you're
talking about on the black at the knees
three two two away
lambert deals and it's a pop-up right
side brian goodwin will take a couple of
steps in and put it away for the third
out of the inning have the bases loaded
here in the second inning with one down
as leori garcia will come to the plate
little topper perez jumps on it sups on
the plate goes to first alertly turns an
inning ending double play
mile straw will lead off for cleveland
lambert's pitch
swung on socked high in the air this
one's headed to deep left center field
this ball gone
the first home run for miles straw and
the cleveland indians uniform he hits
number three and the indians have a
one-nothing lead he is not noted for his
power
but he put it in those bleacher seats
and left center
tough play
what a catch by cesar hernandez
engel i don't believe was gonna get
there
that is a terrific catch by hernandez
one nothing cleveland on top of chicago
bottom of the third and semi zavala
swing and a miss he got him to chase
and gets his second strikeout one down
anderson groundswell weekly to third
easy play for ramirez
throws him out two down
popped him up
that's a great job to get out of the
inning and throw up a zero ronaldo lopez
comes on he's on for the seventh time
see the era of 164. since coming back
from the minor leagues he looks like
he's trying to find a home in the
bullpen and actually been throwing it
pretty well strikes out
this is really a good slider and ronaldo
is starting to pitch differently than he
had before three innings of work for
lambert two hits one run the homer by
straw
and that's gonna be caught on the fly by
hernandez
2-1 pitch
soft grounder to first sheets has it
he'll run it over the bag himself
for the third out of the inning gavin
sheets to lead things off against cal
quantrill
swing and a miss with a high fast ball
third strikeout for quattro one down
here in the fourth well after going down
and in a couple of times he goes and
gets them out away with a high four seam
fastball
one away in the bottom of the fourth is
johan monkatta steps in 2-2 count
there's the strike three on the inside
corner with a fastball back-to-back case
for the first time today for quattro
adam engel will bat with two down bases
empty
strike three quattro strikes out the
side
and we have played four in chicago
laori garcia steps in
bounced into a double play first time up
quantrill delivers and it's a check
swing roller third base side picked up
by quantrill throws to first got him at
first and now you've got two on and the
top of the order tim anderson coming up
going the other way but it's right into
the tracks of bradley zimmer
and there are two down the runners hold
mvp chance from the crowd as jose steps
in
and it hit him and tony out
on the field
and it did hit him and that will tie the
game
but on the heels of what happened friday
night tony's going to come out
and talk with the played umpire who
happens to be the crew chief
this is what happened friday night
he gets hit twice
that time you can live with that
this one is almost tragic i don't
believe a warning has been given to
either side base is loaded no you're not
there's still two outs
they 0-1
popped up is this going to get him out
of the ending jose a long run down into
foul ground hangs on for dear life to
end the inning but the white sox tie the
game
third two outs infield back against
reyes another three
two so lopez with three scoreless
innings
goes again on 100 pitches trying to go
six innings
topper up the middle
ahmed
throws him out heading
over wait did he call him safe
for the moment the white sox had the
lead
he's out not even close okay i didn't
know if he came off the base or
something
he's out let's go getting over aaron
bummer the left-hander here in the
seventh
[Music]
first pitch swing mercado lines to engel
four favorite words for pitcher one
pitch one out homer out of the stretch
exclusively
swinging this
[Applause]
bouncer to third monkata gloves
and we will stretch
well the bullpen has got to try to turn
things around this is a bullpen that at
the end of may had an earned run average
of 285. since then the bullpen's earned
run average is 4 37.
to third jose
[Applause]
one down
parker's pitch is hit fairly well to
left but right there is mercado
two down for cesar hernandez
swinging a miss he struck him out what
an inning by blake parker since lopez
came into the game he and bummer and
kimbrell are now hendricks only one
cleveland batter has reached that was a
rosario double back in the sixth
base hit to center
so a two out base runner and here comes
mercado
[Applause]
[Music]
still working goodwin with one away
here it is
[Applause]
game over
brian goodwin wins it gets a 3-1
fastball and rides it out of the yard
this fastball down the middle he knew it
when it left the bat the fans knew it
i'm going to send them home happy this
beautiful sunday